well Once Upon a Time Joe Biden made
this promise to his vice president
we do the same do the same broccoli we
have lunch alone once a week that's the
deal when we're both in
cuddleman and uh and I see her you know
all the time Flash Forward to today and
amid reports of fighting between their
staffers and it seems like Joe is
avoiding Kamala like the plague
according to public records reviewed by
Real Clear Politics Biden has only
lunched twice this year with his vice
president that comes as liberals fume
over this Politico headline for
referring to Kamala Harris by her first
name they see it as disrespectful sexist
and of course racist so Greg um Brian
Kilmeade was telling me you promised him
lunch every week and that you've been
blowing him off yeah he's very upset
about it well you know he he
he likes to cut my food
which is what uh What uh What uh brought
Biden want keeps asking Kamala to do
that's why they're not having lunch
together anymore because he'd come down
and he would he'd mistake her for the
nurse and say could you cut my food you
know this whole first name business
being sexist I mean tell that to Beyonce
or Madonna or Geraldo if you have a
unique name Kamal is a unique name you
know exactly there's only one Kamala
thank God but I can't go by Greg even
though I'm probably the most famous Greg
on the planet and I include Greg evigan
and Greg Brady and Greg Morris for
Mission Impossible Greg Louganis Greg
Louganis but I'm still bigger than them
but uh yeah so there you go so will my
thought when I heard this was who has
time to actually sit down and have lunch
with anybody anymore I don't have time
to have lunch for an hour with someone
Joe Biden's played the politics of this
like like a beautiful instrument I mean
everyone knows that at least in sports
you want to make sure your backup
quarterback isn't as good as you so when
he plays there's never any threat he
replaces you you in the job I know that
I'm kill meets backup along with hegseth
for Fox and Friends and kill means made
that the case because he knows I'm never
going to take his job Joe Biden knows
Kamala Harris is never taking his job
he's ultimately safe and he doesn't have
to have lunch with her to prove that
once those pictures come out to kill me
though you're set yeah we still have
those yeah
we'll drop them off yeah get it to the
post all right Harold they're blaming
this on staffers fighting with each
other but is that an excuse
you know that's maybe convenient but
I'll tell you this I'm a traditionalist
an old-fashioned I think you call the
president president vice president vice
president I thought the Democrats were
wrong when they'd call Donald Trump
Donald and maybe if you know him well if
I think if you're the president you call
him about you call him by the title two
covet is a reason why they probably
aren't doing the kinds of sit Downs that
they they were often doing and I do
think
what they should be doing when they do
have lunch is figuring out how to get
their poll numbers up and if you if
you're concerned about getting your poll
numbers up you're going to be
representing and serving people who feel
underserved and to to the point that van
Jones made there were a lot of promises
and there been there's been a massive
delivery in a lot of a lot of instances
admit to it cop to it go to Arizona go
to Texas Katie Wright go to these places
and give a speech about what the country
is going to do to fix our border go to
Chicago go to Cleveland go to Memphis go
to Baltimore every week I'd go to these
cities and meet with these police Chiefs
and DA's and say what do you need me to
do put a plan on the table to reform
cashless bail across the country there
were some good things I was trying to do
but the result has not been great that's
what they should be having lunch about
that's what they should be meaning about
and I hope as a president if they do put
them out on the road I hope that's what
he's doing something else what if it was
the opposite what if the vice president
doesn't want to necessarily have lunch
with the president no you know what I
think I I do agree with Greg I I think
that Kamala got tired of having to cut
the food for Joe but what I also think
is Joe got tired of her laughing all the
time because because she laughs all the
time all the food ends up on his plate I
mean you imagine that conversation
terrible situation and I disagree I
disagree I think covet if anything
provides more of an opportunity for them
to have lunch together because nobody's
going out you know look at Putin you put
you know Greg and I could have lunch
they'd be all at the other end
yeah I know I know but what I'm saying
is you're going to have a long table you
can still have lunch and not worry about
covet uh you know what I think she's
very picky she wants everything to be
about race and about sexism remember she
didn't like it when people didn't stand
up when she walked into a room I mean
you know she's a prima donna you know
what earn the people's respect that's
all instead of complaining about racism
those in the White House think about the
people represent people serve people and
let them make those decisions so racist
only after lunch all right demo Friday
is up next hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now